hello everyone as the title suggests
this is the only game ever played
between Mikhail Botvinnik and Bobby
Fischer
now before we check out the game and say
something more about this event we do
have a nice photo challenge so this was
sent to me by a subscriber best of luck
to everyone as this one is definitely
not easy so here it is your your quest
here is the find Frank Marshall and aron
nimzowitsch now if you can find two of
them that's two points and I would also
like to know how many of the players
were you able to recognize here and if
by some miracle someone is able to
recognize all of them then by all means
do share in the comment section so we
can all marvel at your vast knowledge so
like we said Mikhail Botvinnik versus
the 19-year old Bobby Fischer Bobby
Fischer tried to he tried to play a
world champion Mika Botvinnik for a very
long time when he was very young I
remember reading in a book my my friend
Bobby Fischer by Dmitri Bill it'sa that
he heard that Botvinnik was staying at a
hotel and then he traveled on foot with
his umbrella as it was raining and then
when he finally arrived he hit off the
receptionist at the hotel that he was
here to challenge me calm voice a witch
and the reception is just you know sent
him on his way so he did try tries to
challenge both manic plenty of times and
as he never got this chance even boasted
publicly that if he played a match
against the botanique that he would
surely win even if even if he gave
botanique odds so of course this is
quite an important encounter I was
played in the in the Chess Olympiad in
1962 in Varna Bulgaria on board one
Fischer playing board one for the United
States and Botanic of course playing
board one for the Soviets and of course
both manic cannot afford to lose a game
such as this one especially not to to to
Bobby Fischer the 19 year old American
so let's check it out
we have C 4 by botanique g6 d4 Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and d5 now Fischer knows
that botany is a specialist at the groom
for defense
as the groom father did spend quite a
lot of time preparing this for his World
Chess Championship match against miss
love we had nice to f3 here Fischer says
I did take a couple of notes from the
book my 60 memorable games where I will
be using both Fisher and botanics notes
about this game Fisher says that one
botany plays Knight to f3 that he really
played it quickly and that he was he
really knew what he was getting himself
into against the fishers roomful defence
Bishop to g7 we have Queen to b3 the
Russian variation D captures on c4 Queen
captures on c4 and castles Fisher says
that the Queen to b3 followed by Queen C
for isn't isn't doing all that much for
white so he doesn't really care for it
will hit F or Bishop to g4 this is this
missile variation and now comes Bishop
to e3 9th to e5 doesn't give all that
much for white yes he does attack the
bishop but after Bishop e6 d5 and Bishop
to c8 this equalized the game very nice
for black Fisher knows this and
Botvinnik of course knows this as he
does prepare all of these variations for
his match with Smith law so rush of
three three by Botvinnik
and now we have a knight f2 d7 capturing
on f3 doesn't do anything now comes
Bishop to e2 this was a this was very
important as there is a well-known game
why were white castles a knight c6
Bishop to e2 now Knight b6 attacking the
Queen Queen c5 and now Queen to d6 and
after h3 Bishop captures G captures an
f5 this was played in 1965 in Las Vegas
between reshef ski and Evans and white
didn't achieve all that much here so
instead after this night f2 d7 the
botany decided to go back up to e2
immediately we have Knight to c6
we have rook to d1 and now knife the b6
forcing what we need to decide what to
do with the Queen about 20 plays with
the c5 and we have Queen to d6 here
Fischer offers a trade of Queens h3 by
botanique capturing the Queen isn't all
that great because this simply improves
black's pawn structure
you know it emo prevents white Center
from being pushed forward and the white
has white can't even hope to achieve any
advantage here from the opening so after
Queen to d6 botanique plays h3 I would
have a bush of captures G captures and
now rook F to d8 again Queen captures
and c5 isn't isn't good because after D
captures on c5 we have Bishop captures
on c3 pawn captures and now nice play
for but this doesn't work for black
because you're not gonna do anything
King to d2 is coming and even after
black checksum King is coming to c2 and
this is very very nice position for
white so after G captors on f3 Fischer
goes rook F to d8 we have
d5 now d5 Fischer says that this cannot
be a good move as Fischer says that both
we should admit that he didn't get
anything out of the opening and that he
definitely shouldn't advance a central
pawn like this looking for advantage
which simply isn't there but okay we
have D v e5 also not really possible
because after a5 Queen captures on c5 d
captors and see if I broke characters
King captures and not knife to d7
attacking the pawn and after f4 f k f g5
f captors and g5 and Bishop captures
here and it's white didn't really
achieve anything there so after this
rook F to D 8 D 5 by botanique we have
Knight to e5 and now of course by
pressuring that f3 Square nice the b5
botanique ET forces Fischer to capture
his queen and c5 or to react to this
somehow somehow either you will capture
it or move the Queen but here a Fischer
plays Queen to f6 and we have f4
night e to D 7 and now comes C 5 and
this is the this is the position
botanique had analyzed a lot because
instead of E 5 you could play Queen
captures here but then Queen captures on
b2 and white white is in trouble here
Queen B
four check is coming you didn't really
achieve anything you're never gonna
Castle
not the greatest position for white so
here after night 87 botanique play d5
and here botanique says these are both
eunuchs notes from the book he says that
he analyzed this position thoroughly
especially prepared for his match
against miss love he prepared against
Queen at five he prepared against Queen
to h4 and in all of these variations
white gets a very a very nice game but
the move Fischer played he didn't even
consider during his analysis here
Fischer played Queen captures on f4 and
this is terrible because it's terrible
for white because now nobody is playing
I wasn't explaining a variation that he
was extremely prepared for so it's
actually Fisher who's supposed to be in
trouble here but now Fischer played
Queen captures on f4 and our botanique
has to really start playing chess as he
no longer and no longer can play this
position from memory and the problem is
you can't go into some munch fest idea
like Queen capture some b6
I like grabbing a piece so if he
captures you're gonna capture his Queen
because of this screen to e4 move now
attacking the rook and after f3 blocking
Queen to h4 now this comes with to check
if you move the King then the Queen will
fall and after this Bishop to have two
blocking then comes Queen to b4 check
and now whatever you play white will
lose the Queen take captures and b6 and
it's all over so after this Queen
captures on f4
you have to play Bishop captures on f4
here at Fischer played Knight captures
on c5 we have Knight captures on c7 rook
a to c8 kicking the knight back d6 now
forwarding the pawn all the way and
protecting deny he captures he captures
and now Bishop captures on b2 and if you
look at this position out of out of
nowhere Fischer is now actually up upon
against against Mikhail Botvinnik
so Botvinnik says that okay fisheries up
a pawn but but when it does have the
bishop pair he does have a very strong
test D pawn and to maybe counter the
extra pawn he just needs to develop now
so what we need castles we have Knight
be
seven preparing Bishop to e5 and now
comes a rook to d5
that's why botanic says that this night
should stay here and guard b5 that he
shouldn't throw out this night that if I
moved it better was night this night
this see knife to d7 preparing Bishop to
e5 but okay Fischer goes for this and we
have looked to d5 and now comes b6 you
have to defend the knight on c5 now
Bishop to f3 here about when he says
that he didn't really like this move
that Bishop on f3 okay it is developed
but it will mostly serve to be as a
target he says that Bishop to c4 would
have been much better here okay Bishop
to f3 we have 96 attacking the bishop on
f4 96 now capturing F captures on e6 and
now rook to d3
we have knife the c5 attacking the rook
rook to e3 and now II five a very nice
idea by Fischer because idea of Bishop
to d4 doesn't work after Luke a3
attacking the a7 pawn you have to do
something so after E 5 Bishop to g5
attacking the rook and after rook
captures and out comes Bishop to e7 and
it doesn't matter where you go the two
bishops are simply too strong and will
pick up at least one rook
so captures Bishop captures and black
will be down the exchange but it's very
interesting the engine actually prefers
this position for black so it thinks
that two extra pawns
regardless of being down the exchange
will will be will be
you know sufficient for black to
actually put four advantage here but
okay after rook e3 we have E 5
immediately by Fischer Bishop captures
we have Bishop captures rook captures
and now Rock captors and e6
grabbing the very strong d6 pawn rook to
e7
we have rook to these seven and here
rook captures Knight captures and Bishop
to g4 Botvinnik says that Bishop to g4
is basically a waste of a move you're
not gonna do anything here as Fischer
simply defended it you can't capture and
go into a rook endgame being down upon
as this would be winning for black so we
have rook to e1 King to f7
rooked King to g2 nice
see five now and rook to e3 we have rook
to e7 and now rook to f3 check here
Botvinnik thought that he could actually
capture here and after Cain captures
bring his King over into the game
because if he if he can get his King
over to a nice central square maybe put
his Bishop on c2
and you know block the position somehow
perhaps would a four then this would be
fine but the problem is after h5 the
bishop is trapped at the only square for
the bishop is c8 but now you can see
this very nice relationship between a
knight and the bishop the knight
controls all of the bishops wears a king
the eight will simply win the bishop so
here both make couldn't capture the
rogue he played rook to f3 check King g7
I would have rocked the c3 and now rook
to e4 Bishop to d1 rook to d4 attacking
the bishop bishop to c2 and now came to
have sex Fischer brings his King into
the game King to f3 we have King to g5
and now comes King back to g3 and here
Botvinnik thought I said that when this
position was on the board he was he was
sure that he was doomed he was just
waiting for the proper moment to have
four young for his young adversary to
win this game and fortunately for both
winning Fisher didn't realize that
botanique was actually in tubes one here
so in anymore watch eunuch maid would
pretty much ruin ruin the game for him
here Fischer went for ninety four check
he forced an exchange of of night and
Bishop and went into a rock end game but
here as Botvinnik suggests a5 simply
wins the game for black because now the
white is in soup swung and there is
nothing white can do if white tries for
example to move the King let's say King
g2 then you get into h4 and now that the
king is an h4 there's no moving the king
away from h4 simply nice to e6 followed
by Knight f4 will win the H pawn Knight
captures pawn another idea after a 5 is
you could go rush up the b1 if you move
the bishop then rook to d1 it will be
winning the bishop is under attack
and if you move the bishop then rocks
one again is winning King moves and now
rook to a-1 attacking the a to pawn and
once you take care of this
you can either protect it with the
bishop and now you can either go king
gage for winning the h4 square or you
can even exchange here captures captures
and after captures here you have to
defend the f2 pawn and here a four you
can even give up the b6 bone and do win
the game easily and another thing after
this if I move if you decide to move the
rook let's say rope here then Rock the
c-4 will be decisive attacking the
bishop bishop moves then comes Knight to
e4 check you have to defend the f2 pawn
after King moves 90 to check King moves
Knight captures rook captures and here
rook to e4 will again be sufficient to
win the game a3 in defending but now
King to f4 and white doesn't really have
a good move here you have to capture a
pawn and then after captures the a pawn
will be winning so yeah this was an
excellent position for Fisher but
Fischer thought that 94 was also winning
forcing forcing this exchange and going
into a Roxanne game so Bishop captures
was played rook captures and now rook to
a3 botanique says that rook to a3 is not
the best move that he would prefer if
he'd played a rope to c7 and then I flew
up to a for capturing on h7 and then
after rook captures here F for this
check King f5 and now check King moves
and now rook the rook here preventing
this pawn from being pushed as this pawn
would fall and then maybe the King can
go into the game and hold this position
but after this rook to e4
he played rook to a3 we have rook to e7
by Fischer Rock to f3 and now rook to c7
here we have a 4 and this is move 45 and
here the game was adjourned
Fischer has to seal a move and the move
he sealed well of course but he did not
know which move was sealed and it was
only it was only the next day that the
game had continued and you know
overnight of course botanique and his
entire team of grandmasters were
analyzing this game trying to save this
game for
and after a whole night of analysis in
the morning they were having breakfast
and someone from the other team as
Botvinnik what of the game Botvinnik
can you pull it off and Botvinnik you
know just calmly responded a draw and
quickly you know the word spread and
everyone thought okay so basically
Fisher Fisher Blewett he could have won
that game but fish are actually still
thought that he will win this game so
the next day the game continued we have
worked the c5 by Fischer this was the
sealed move rook to f7 now attacking the
h7 point this was botanique strongest
idea rook to a5 now rook to h7 capturing
the pawn rook captures on e4 and now h4
Fischer says that he also analyzed this
position previously but he thought that
Botvinnik would have played f4 here but
he says that h4 is also very nice even
stronger King to f5 we have rook to f7
check King moves and now rook to g7
attacking the pawn and now you can see
that with the weak Jeep on and the Queen
side pawns Fischer has aren't really all
that mobile just yet it's very hard to
produce anything here here rook to e1
was played and now King to f3 of course
you don't want to capture the pawn here
and then you would get a rope to g1 so
first hide the king and now b5 but when
it says that b5 is one way to go about
it but that he also analyzed King d5 and
king d4 and that this also draws for
black and later it was found both unique
even wrote articles about this move and
about this game you know the game was
analyzed intensively and later after you
know strong engines appeared this game
was analyzed by strong engines and I
have no idea what the final word is
about the game now with supercomputers
maybe the supercomputer will say that
the game is winning for white but I do
not have access to this information
so after b5 we have h5 now of course now
the creating this will will be very hard
for black to do anything if you capture
then rule d5 immediately will win back
the pawn king before rook captures and
now of course it's a draw so here after
h5
have a look to a3 this comes with check
King g2 and now G captures on h5 Brooke
g5 this comes with check King d6 and
rook captures on b5 getting rid of that
very strong pawn and but regardless even
if beef I wasn't pushed at about tunic
showed that King d5 or d4 would have
also been a draw if you if you have you
know if you are able to you know you can
always acquire my 60-member memorable
games and check out this game for
ourselves h4 and by Fischer we have F
for now king c6 rugby 8 h3 with check
King H to now comes a five now we have
f5 King c7 Rob here we have King King to
d6 and hear what Nick says that the
disposition is a theoretical draw even
if even if white didn't have the F pawn
so if even if you disposition porn did
not exist here it will also be a draw
botanique pushes f6 we have King e6 room
b6 check King f7 rook a6 King g6 now
rogue back to c6 rook the b6 also
doesn't really do anything as after a
four Rock a 16 to f7 a rugby 643 Rock a
six a three and King to g1 it wouldn't
really wouldn't really do anything
so after this King to g6 we have worked
the c6 a for now rook to a6 King to f7
Luke the c6 rug d3 rope to a six a three
and after King to g1 the game was a draw
as there is there is no way to push for
any advantage here with with black
either you will either you you can check
the King and then King h2 will win back
this point will win this point or if you
simply move the rook then this point
will be won and that's pretty much it
you can ever win this pawn and the
position is our one on theoretical draw
so yeah that's the game the only game
ever played between Michael botanique
and a 19 year old Bobby Fischer and
Fischer was a was very unsatisfied after
this game he really as he boasted
so much about that he would be able to
defeat botanique especially if they
played a match and especially if he gave
bot 20 cards and he he always said that
the botanique wasn't a very strong world
champion he always said that tal was was
a much stronger than him and that a lot
of Russian players were stronger than
him so this draw didn't really go
Fischer's way so yeah there was even I
found there is even a very short video
20 seconds on YouTube about this
encounter here you can see this is after
the match Fischer very unsatisfied
getting up from the table and both
unique there you can see a smile on his
face he was able to draw again against
Bobby Fischer with the white pieces so
no no shame for for Russia so yeah I
will also put a link in the description
to this video although like I said it's
a 20 second video not really not really
much to enjoy there but yeah we do have
we do even have a photo of this
encounter so there we have him others
Fischer and botanic all both of them
still still like stone so yeah that's
basically it I do hope you enjoyed it
and you know the Allah a lot of things
have been said about this game whether
it was winning it that position losing
it that position and then facial wrote
in his book that it was winning then a
Botanic wrote that it wasn't then
Botanic publish tab I believe Kasparov's
notes that the game was not winning for
Fischer then you know it was a complete
chaos but yeah yeah once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank I
got masters dog and guilt or it's up for
a contribution to my channel think a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon hopefully with another interesting
video and I also started a poll about my
next video series the link to it will
also be in the description but also if
you haven't voted I feel free to check
it out and drop your vote as every vote
counts so yeah thank you all and I will
see you soon